American Horror Story can be horrifying, and
it's made even more chilling when you consider
that many of the villains and victims across
its various stories are drawn from the real-life
crimes, both solved and unsolved, that populate
American history.
The first season of American Horror Story
was retroactively dubbed Murder House.
It's a fitting name for a season that saw
Connie Britton and Dylan McDermott star as
Vivien and Ben Harmon, a couple who move with
their teenage daughter Violet into a Los Angeles
mansion.
As you can probably guess, the mansion is
haunted, and the Harmon's are constantly confronted
by the ghosts of those who have been murdered
there.
Among their many supernatural roommates is
Elizabeth Short, known to history as "The
Black Dahlia."
"I'm an actress.
I'm gonna make it big!
Everyone says so.
You can expect to see me on the silver screen
one day."
Mena Suvari played the AHS version of Short:
an aspiring actor, desperate to be famous,
who visits the house in the late '40s for
a dental appointment that turns lethal.
In reality, Short was indeed a Hollywood hopeful
who went missing in early January 1947.
Her body was discovered six days later near
a park, horribly mutilated and posed in a
grotesque fashion.
The crime was never solved, though one police
detective has written a compelling book full
of evidence suggesting that his late father,
who was a doctor, was responsible.
The second season of AHS was subtitled Asylum
and focused on the patients and staff of Briarcliff,
a sanitarium in New England, during the 1960s.
One of the asylum's residents was Kit Walker.
He lived happily with his wife Alma until
the interracial couple was visited by extraterrestrials
who abducted her.
Kit's ensuing psychological breakdown leads
authorities to believe that he offed his missing
wife, and he's sent to Briarcliff.
"Did you murder your wife?"
"No.
And I'm not crazy."
"That's unfortunate.
If they decide you're sane, you're going someplace
way worse than this."
Barney and Betty Hill were the model for Kit
and Alma's story, though they thankfully suffered
no homicide allegations as a result of the
visitation they claim to have experienced
in 1961.
While driving the backroads of New Hampshire,
they saw what Betty described as a shooting
star falling upwards that pursued their car.
Suddenly the pair found themselves 35 miles
from where they had been only moments earlier.
Their watches had stopped working, and they'd
lost two hours of time.
Under hypnosis, the couple claimed to recall
details of their visitation.
They were credible, as it seemed unlikely
that an interracial couple in the 1960s would
want to draw further attention to themselves.
Betty claimed to continue to experience visitations
for years following her abduction.
New Orleans provides the magical setting for
Coven, the third installment of AHS, which
draws on the historical legacy of the Crescent
City to populate its cast of characters.
One of the show's most memorable monsters
is Madame Delphine LaLaurie, whose horrific
torture of her slaves reached levels of inhumanity
made even more ghastly by Kathy Bates' unsettling
performance and the real-life suffering that
inspired it.
"It wasn't 150 slaves that died up here — I
can tell you that."
"Sorry?"
"It was 62."
Bates brings LaLaurie to life over 150 years
after the suspected death of the real Madame
Delphine, who was born in New Orleans in the
late 18th century.
She lived a privileged life as a socialite
for a time, until reports began to emerge
that Delphine mistreated her slaves.
The claims were not investigated, though the
city did have laws against such abuse.
Following the suspected killing of a young
slave in her care, LaLaurie's house caught
fire in 1834 and revealed the family had indeed
brutalized those in her workforce — the
slaves had been starved, shackled at the neck
with spiked collars, and subjected to torture.
Enraged by this cruelty, an angry mob ransacked
the house, and Delphine fled the city for
Paris.
On AHS, Marie Laveau is a powerful, immortal
Voodoo Queen played by Angela Bassett, whose
desire for revenge against Madame LaLaurie
leads her to form her own cult of followers.
"Don't think that they didn't suffer, because
they did — greatly.
But the fate that I have planned for you will
make their suffering seem as a gentle sleep."
In the modern-day timeline of Coven, she alternately
makes and breaks alliances with the coven
of witches lead by Fiona Goode, descended
from the victims of the Salem Witch Trials.
Confirmed details of the life of the real
Marie Laveau, who was born to a creole mother
and white father at the turn of the 19th century,
are scant.
The woman herself, a Catholic who wove threads
of African and Native-American traditions
into her religious practice, was reluctant
to tell her own story, according to her 1881
obituary in the New York Times.
What is known is that Laveau worked as a hairdresser,
a detail represented in her AHS counterpart,
and that this work informed her role as a
spiritual adviser to the wealthy and powerful
people of New Orleans, who flocked to her
for guidance in matters both personal and
professional.
A traveling show of human curiosities star
in the fourth season of AHS.
Led by scheming ringmaster Elsa Mars, the
carnival performers of AHS: Freak Show are
misunderstood by the public, who perceive
them as monstrous because of their unique
appearances.
Among them is Pepper, a microcephalic woman
recruited by Elsa after her family abandoned
her to an orphanage.
Her first appearance, however, wasn't in Freak
Show.
She actually first popped up in Asylum, where
her storyline diverged from that of her historical
inspiration.
"Play with me!"
"Play with meee!"
Pepper, as played by Naomi Grossman in both
Asylum and Freak Show, was based on Schlitze
Surtees, a real carnival performer.
Schlitze is thought to be a man named Simon
Metz, born in 1901 in Bronx, NY.
His parentage is unknown, but his condition
relegated his brain development to that of
a young child.
He performed with the Ringling Brothers Circus
and at Coney Island in the late '20s before
being cast in Tod Browning's 1932 MGM cult
classic Freaks.
He took the last name Surtees from his guardian
George, a former carnival barker and chimpanzee
trainer.
Schlitze became one of the most well-known
carnival performers of his era, costumed in
a dress and billed as a woman.
During the events of Freak Show, Elsa discovers
conjoined twins Dot and Bette Tattler and
convinces them to join her troupe.
Dot is reluctant, and relents only to please
her sister Bette, who dreams of becoming a
star.
Playing the role of two different sisters
on the same series would be a challenge for
any actor, but Sarah Paulson's a pro — and
she successfully portrayed the twins with
ease and believability.
"Elsa, you can be the fairy grandmother that
grants the wish of the plane Jane — that's
Dot — and transforms her into the epitome
of Glamour.
That's me."
The physiology of the Tattler sisters was
inspired by real-life conjoined sisters Abby
and Brittany Hensel, whose 2003 documentary
Joined for Life was closely reviewed by Paulson
in preparation for the part.
Yet the story of the Tattlers follows the
lives of a different set of twins: Violet
and Daisy Hilton.
These conjoined sisters, like Bette and Dot,
suffered the abuse of their guardians during
their early years in show business.
The pair toured the carnival circuit and even
starred with Schlitze Surtees in Freaks.
The sisters saw great success for a time,
and eventually liberated themselves from their
guardians on the advice of Harry Houdini.
Eventually, interest in their act dwindled
and they spent their last years working in
a grocery store before they passed away in
1969, dying a few days apart.
James March built the Hotel Cortez, where
the bloody events of AHS: Hotel take place.
You see, March was no benevolent hotelier.
In fact, he specifically designed the place
around his violent tendencies, fashioning
rooms that enabled him to commit any number
of killings within its walls.
March is clearly modeled on real-life serial
killer H.H. Holmes, who did build a hotel
designed for homicide.
It featured gas jets, which turned guest rooms
into deadly chambers, and a wooden chute that
allowed for bodies to be swiftly disposed
of in an incinerator.
His "murder hotel" claimed the lives of many
young women who visited there in connection
with the 1893 Chicago World's Fair.
When he was finally caught, Holmes confessed
to taking the lives of 30 people, though authorities
believe he may have been responsible for nearly
200 deaths.
He was hanged for his crimes in 1896.
His hotel was later intended to be remodeled
as a "Murder Castle" attraction but was destroyed
by a fire before it's opening.
"Like the Iliad, your stories will live on…
forever."
The fourth episode of Hotel features a deadly
dinner party hosted by Mr. March.
A who's who of famous criminals check in to
attend the festivities, which they've attended
annually for many years.
Yup — the guests of March's party are some
of the most famous real serial killers in
American history.
The first guest to check in is Richard Ramirez,
known as the Night Stalker, who was responsible
for at least 13 deaths in the 1980s.
The next killer to turn up at the hotel is
Aileen Wuornos , who confessed to the deaths
of six men she claimed assaulted her while
she worked as a prostitute.
Jeffrey Dahmer, who killed at least 11 people,
also turns up.
Evidence indicates Dahmer may have consumed
some of the remains of his victims.
"Jeffrey?
You're even more quiet than usual tonight."
"I'm just hungry."
He's joined for dinner by none other than
John Wayne Gacy, who dressed as a clown in
his free time and also took the lives of 33
men.
In its sixth year, AHS decided to change things
up a bit and brought us Roanoke, which is
styled as a found-footage documentary.
Roanoke — or, at least, its first half — follows
a young couple living in an old mansion known
as Roanoke House, near the site of the lost
Roanoke colony in Virginia.
Roanoke was a real colony from the 16th century
that represented the first attempt to establish
an English settlement in North America.
When the community's founder returned from
a two-year voyage, its inhabitants had all
vanished, leaving the word "Croatoan" carved
into a tree nearby.
Another nod to this history is series character
Tomasyn White, played by Kathy Bates's My
Roanoke Nightmare character, Agnes Mary Winstead.
White was a real person, and was indeed married
to John White, founder of the Roanoke colony.
"Were thou not birthed of mine own treacherous
flesh, I would cut thy throat and hurl thee
into bloody damnation."
While there's no evidence to suggest she accompanied
White to his colony in Virginia, their union
produced two children, including their daughter
Elizabeth.
Elizabeth bore a son at Roanoke, who vanished
along with his mother and father and the rest
of the colony between 1588 and 1590.
The 2016 U.S. Presidential election gave AHS
plenty of fuel for the story of Cult, their
seventh season.
In the turbulent post-election times, a cult
forms in a small town in Michigan.
One of its associates reveals she had a love
affair with none other than Valerie Solanas,
the woman who shot Andy Warhol, the famous
pop artist and leader of the studio known
as the Factory, which drew artists and luminaries
of all kinds to congregate and experiment.
In the AHS universe, Solanas was also responsible
for the Zodiac killings.
In reality, that series of slayings was carried
out by an unknown person in the Bay area who
taunted police with a series of cryptic messages
sent to local newspapers in the late '60s.
Solanas only attempted to kill Warhol and
Mario Amaya, an art dealer.
Both men lived, but Warhol had to wear a surgical
corset for the rest of his life.
The crime saw Solanas sentenced to three years
in prison.
She suffered from schizophrenic paranoia that
complicated her rehabilitation, and died in
a welfare hotel in San Francisco in 1988.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.